las vegas now former news anchor kathy
lee gifford has shifted her passion to
becoming a songwriter playwright and
author so jillian caught up with her
just in time for the release of her new
book and new movie take a look
cathy you're a busy woman you have a lot
going on i love following along with
everything that you're doing but let's
jump right into it you were telling me a
fun fact before we even started this
interview so what came first your book
or your movie
well chicken or the egg right uh you
know most people assume that that movies
are made from a book that's not true at
all this is the opposite i was uh i had
written a film three and a half years
ago with my friend nicole c mullen that
had an
outrageous reaction on youtube and it
proved to me that this is what i was
supposed to do is
write that that movie was called the god
who sees
and millions of people watched it had it
it was just anointed of the holy spirit
people were being healed people were
being saved people were not committing
suicide because they did they finally
believed that god saw them i mean i
could tell
this is not something that two women
write that's just you know another piece
of theater another song whatever it had
a life to it and it was vibrant it was
powerful
she's traveling
what we wrote is technically called an
oratorio it's storytelling but with
music underneath it and i have the
national symphony orchestra players
underneath me 65 of them with some of
the most outrageous music you've heard
in years i think well and kathy i feel
like you've just entered this next
chapter and kind of have found your
calling you have such a successful
journalism career and now here you are
spreading your your message of
positivity and also we talked about when
you are a grandma you have this
beautiful family i know your
daughter-in-law erica from out here in
las vegas do you just feel like you are
where you're meant to be right now
can you tell
yeah everybody goes how could you leave
your dream job with regis leave your
dream job with soda no
i'm doing my dream job right now this is
what i
didn't even realize god was it was was
doing inside me but i came out of the
womb wanting to be an actress and a
singer and a and a writer
and i've done that all along people just
didn't know i was doing it all along
after you go on my
imdb
it's a
pages and pages long and it was it's of
tv shows and movies and broadway and and
i looked at it i said you got to see
that i go why i said you're not going to
believe how much stuff you've done i
know really i could just do it the bible
comes to life with music and narration
in ways you've never experienced before
so the movie is called the way it will
be a fathom event on september 1st that
means it's going to be in theaters for
one night only all over the country it's
going to be right there in las vegas
so kathy kathy lee gifford's book the
way in her movie the god of way are both
available now that was really cool i
know she's allegedly interviewed las
vegas now we'll be right back